It's one thing if we don't know a person or the background.
But when you know a person,
when there's a Laura Loomer,
a Milo Yiannopoulos and it's a public case and then you,
you get this feeling that the say no cause we decide and this is it.
Well Joe,
don't worry because no matter what Twitter does,
they're going to be defended by the New York digital,
you know,
journalist elites who will misrepresent what's going on in an effort to obvious
gate or sometimes outright lie about what's going on.
And this brings me to learn to code.
Yeah.
Okay.
So learn to code.
So I asked you about this the other day that people are getting banned for learn
to code.
I'm like,
what the fuck is that?
Like what is that?
So when coal miners were getting laid off a bunch of articles and merge saying
teaching miners to code,
can we teach miners how to code?
And they were showing videos about it.
I don't believe it was,
it wasn't intended to be a derogatory or insulting,
but to a lot of people that came off as this bourgeois,
let them eat cake.
Oh,
your career has been destroyed.
You're,
you're,
you're a 50 year old man with a family.
Go to Silicon Valley into something you've never even thought about.
Right.
Let's,
so it came off as to a lot of people as just elitist,
right?
So when these journalists are getting laid off,
this meme spreads,
I don't know exactly where it started,
um,
where they'd say learn to code to the journalists.
Well,
this is an interesting thing happens.
John Levine,
I think his name from the Rep tweets,
someone from Twitter told me,
you will,
you can,
you can be banned for tweeting.
Learn to code at a laid off journalists conservative.
Start tweeting it far and wide.
Like,
here we go.
This is a reporter from the rep was confirmed this.
All of a sudden then other journalists can come out and say,
this is a lie.
This is not true.
This is fake news.
Conservatives are spreading fake news again and they say,
we have a new,
a new statement from Twitter that said,
we're only in banning.
We're only banning people who are engaging in a harassment campaign.
Now I've got a few problems.
Is tweeting a meme at somebody's critical of them a harassment campaign?
Is that a meme it,
yeah,
right.
It's like it condensed as an idea and,
So here's the thing.
I got sent a bunch of screenshots,
screenshots from people.
Now people can fake screenshots.
I understand that some,
but,
but I checked some people's Twitter accounts.
I saw that they were tweeting this and I believe for the most part,
this is what happened.
Someone tweeted something to a buzzfeed journalists,
you know,
oh,
you guys believed x,
y,
and Z.
Yeah,
whatever.
Hashtag learned to code criticizing them suspension.
So then these,
these journalists come out and say,
this is not true.
It's just people engaging in harassment campaign.
So I said,
look at this guy's account.
He's got one tweet that says learn to code.
Is that him harassing somebody?
And they said,
oh,
but you're taken out of context.
Then John Levine from the rep says,
update Twitter spokesperson who was my source is now saying clarifying it is
about the harassment campaign.
And then another journalist comes out and says he his quotes fake Twitter's deny
ever saying it.
But here's the thing,
the editor in chief of the daily caller,
just a couple of I think a couple of days ago took a tweet from the daily show
and and it was,
it was a a from the state of the Union and he tweeted learn to code and quote
tweeted a video suspended.
So it's very clearly not about a harassment campaign,
but why then we're all of these journalists so ready to jump up and defend
Twitter when Twitter,
you know what I said?
Okay.
If Twitter is claiming they're banning people who are engaging in harassment
campaign you,
you mean they've confirmed their banning people for tweeting learn to code.
They just consider it harassment.
How is it that learned to code is harassment but Kathy Griffin sang to all of
our millions of fans.
I want these kids names several times or another verified account.
I'm not going to name cause not as famous.
Literally calling for the death of these kids and instructing people to kill
them is not a Beneful offense.
It's not harassment campaigns.
That's true.
Uh,
I don't want to,
I don't want to mention the guy's name,
but yes,
absolutely.
He said something to the effect of put them in a school,
lock it and burn it down.
And when you see them fire on them,
this guy is still active on Twitter.
They're,
you know,
right now there are anti,
so now we can,
there's,
there's so much of your dude.
Yeah,
we've got the proud boys.
All of them purged from Twitter.
Okay.
Say whatever you want about the proud boys.
If they deserve to be banned,
fine.
Why wasn't Antifa Bend?
A lot of people respond to me and say,
but Tim Antifa is random people who wear masks.
You don't know.
That's not true.
There are branded sells of Antifa that have their own merchandise.
Still active.
Some of these groups have published the private information of law enforcement
officers.
Still active.
No action taken against them.
So,
you know,
I,
I don't,
so this,
this indicates a heavy left wing bias.
I wouldn't necessarily say left wing,
I would say intersectional identity,
Marian Ideological bias,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's hard to pinpoint what the tribes are in the culture war,
but Twitter is clearly acting in defense of intersectional activism.
Now,
do you think that this is a mandate?
Do you think this is written somewhere?
Do you think there is people who are in the company that have power,
that are acting independently?
It's,
it's uh,
grains of sand to make a heap,
right?
You're in,
you're in silicon valley,
you're in a very blue area.
The people who get hired tend to hold certain views and because they all live in
their own bubble,
they believe they're the majority and bus,
they think they're acting justly to ban those who are at odds with them.
And the social engineering,
and this brings back into journalism,
the big problem,
it's,
you know,
for decades,
I don't know how long journalism has been dominated by self identified liberals.
There's a ton of polls.
I think it was a 2015 poll showing republicans are like 7% of journalists or
some ridiculously small number.
And is it really simple reason for it?
News organizations are headquartered in big cities,
the big ones,
you know,
see and even Fox News in New York.
So there's a lot of people who work at Fox News.
We're actually liberal.
People don't seem to know that you live in New York,
you're probably not a staunch conservative.
So what happens then?
News breaks.
You've got all these journalists,
cause I've worked with them.
You know I worked for vice,
I worked for fusion and they sit around at tables,
they meet up after work from different offices and they talk about things and
they all tell each other the exact same thing.
And so this is why you see Covington happen.
These people follow each other on Twitter.
So when someone tweets this,
a kid got in the face of Nathan Phillips,
they only see each other's tweets and they just write it.
They don't do any journalism.
And it goes,
it,
man,
I can't believe for days.
And then it was even in the New York Times,
correct?
Yeah.
Yep.
No,
The New York Times,
uh,
Harris talked about that yet.
And it's mind blowing to me because the second video that came out from
Covington,
you literally watch Nathan Phillips Walk into up to the kid and get his face
Bill Maher.
You know,
what,
four or five days later it says,
the kid got in his face and I'm like,
how are you?
Yeah.
You know,
shame on Bill Maher for,
for,
for saying that it's not true,
but at the same time we have a serious journalism problem and this links back to
Twitter and that story in particular release almost like condensed all of the
problems into one yet yet.
And what's,
what's,
what's fascinating is following the story,
an op Ed,
I believe it was in New York Times said stop tweeting arts had never tweet Brian
Stelter from CNN.
Then got a statement that I always say I believe because I don't have the
sources pulled up,
but someone from Twitter said journalists are the lifeblood of our platform.
And so that's why I think you've got these predominantly New York based
progressive writers.
They're fresh out of college.
They get hired for,
you know,
moderate salaries to work in a newsroom,
sit around each other all day,
sharing the same ideas,
not exploring anything outside their bubble.
And Twitter supports them because they're the ones who drive traffic to Twitter.
They keep the conversation going.
And I think that's where Twitter's bias partly comes from the other,
is that clearly you're in San Francisco,
you're going to have,
you know,
your,
your staff,
the people who are,
who are,
you know,
running content curation and banning people.
They lean left.
So why,
why?
Uh,
Kathy Griffin was in band probably because she's very famous,
but then I have to wonder why Alex Jones was so you,
the only,
the only real differentiator that I guess is either mainstream notoriety or
ideological tribe.